we're going to do randomized Fibonacci
sequences so we're gonna pick a
Fibonacci sequence we're gonna randomize
it with this coin I think we should do a
recap of Fibonacci sequences first as to
see what the original Fibonacci sequence
is so your fibonacci sequence starts
with a 1 and a 1 and then the next term
is the sum of the previous two we're
going to add those together so one plus
one makes two
one plus two makes three two and three
make five eight and all 13 21 and so on
so if you want to write that down as a
little formula you'd write it like this
if you want to don't find the next
Fibonacci number you just add the
previous two okay so couple of
well-known facts about Fibonacci numbers
as well if you take two consecutive
Fibonacci numbers it will divide the big
one by the small one then you'll see and
it's been proven for a long time that
this will tend to a number which is one
point six one eight zero three three
nine eight eight something something and
people will know that this is a special
number this is called the golden ratio
which is this symbol the golden ratio
but you can use that to estimate let's
say you've got a really big Fibonacci
number and you don't know what it is you
can use the golden ratio
so the idea is every time we're sort of
multiplying by the golden ratio to get
the next one up unless true at the
beginning becomes more true the bigger
these numbers are so you can kind of
like reverse engineer your numbers yeah
yes you can work out the millionth
Fibonacci number right so if you wanted
to work out the millionth Fibonacci
number what you're doing is multiplying
by the golden ratio a million times so
let's say approximately equal to golden
ratio which is this symbol to a million
and I can tell you what that is I've
actually worked this out four point four
times ten and it's going to be a huge
number two hundred and eight thousand
and eighty-seven so this is a really big
Fibonacci number but this is an estimate
because it is
do you want to see what it actually is
the actual millionth Fibonacci number is
1.9 five times ten to the power two
hundred and eight thousand nine hundred
and eighty-seven there so not quite
there but the size of these numbers is
spot-on so that's just a little recap of
Fibonacci because what I want to do now
is randomize this Fibonacci we know
everything about it our boring so
predictable so now let's use my coin to
randomize this a little bit with this
idea when I create a random Fibonacci
sequence the next one it's going to be
the sum or the difference of the
previous two numbers so we're going to
start in the same way with a 1 and a 1
now what is the next value you're gonna
use my coin to find out so normally it
would have been two
so this is this if it was that the
ordinary Fibonacci sequence we would add
these together we get a two I'm gonna
flip my coin I might take the Sun I
might take the difference so let's see
what it's going to be you've got a
negative on one side okay so I've
prepared
I came prepped ready yeah all right
let's do is it a sum or difference and
I've got difference difference okay so
it's no what is the next night show zero
is the next number let's do the next
number is it give me a sum or difference
it's going to be a song so I've got one
now at the previous two to give me one
let's see what I get next let's try it
whip okay I got some so we've got back
to another one there okay I've got plus
so that's a two let's keep going is it a
sum or a difference
now got different so we're going to do
two minus one gives me a one let's do a
few more
you got a plus now so that's going to be
a three 201 oh and a difference here so
three minus one is a 2 so it's
unpredictable I don't know what's going
to happen next and if you don't mind and
when I really make that point if I did
it again I'm going to get a different
sequence but is there anything I can say
about them so I don't know if these are
going to you know go off to infinity
like the Fibonacci sequence just gets
bigger and bigger and bigger goes off to
infinity I don't know if it's gonna
maybe it just goes off to minus infinity
I don't know that maybe it kind of
hovers around zero maybe the pluses and
minuses cancel out or maybes
unpredictable maesters chaotic and I
don't know what's going to happen next
so the surprise is I can make some
predictions I can make some long-term
predictions for example I can tell you
what the millionth random Fibonacci
number is going to be because like the
original Fibonacci sequence
there is a growth ratio just the same
way I want to show you that so it's one
point one three one nine eight eight two
four eight seven nine four three
something something something okay so
this is our constant and it's going on
forever which means we can use this to
predict the millionth random number so
let's do it
random Fibonacci number one million
same kind of thing I did with the
Fibonacci numbers it's going to be
approximately this constant or I'll just
do one point three one nine you get the
idea to the power one mininum which is
some big number eight point three times
ten to the fifty 3841
I will tell you this is a statement
about the size of the number not the
sign of the number so I don't know if
it's a plus or minus number so it might
be a plus or minus so this might be
going off to positive and
he might and there's no reason why I
can't go down to negative infinity but
they are growing and the size of these
numbers are growing and in long term we
can predict how much it will grow by if
you want to put it another way you could
say it like this if we take the nth
random Fibonacci number and make it
positive and we took the nth root
this is tending to odd a magic number
here one point one three one nine and
stuff as n tends to infinity although
well I'll put a little thing here almost
surely that's a funny expression I've
slipped in this tends to this constant
almost surely because the original
Fibonacci sequence would count as I
randomize Fibonacci sequence if I was
just getting plus every time I flip my
coin plus plus plus plus so that count
and that has a growth rate which is the
golden ratio it's not this value but the
chances of me getting plus plus plus
over and over again so I've got the
Fibonacci sequence becomes increasingly
small so if you look at all the possible
random Fibonacci sequence things like
the original Fibonacci sequence almost
never happens I'm not going to say it's
impossible but it's almost never going
to happen
you did this for real almost 100 percent
of the time you're getting a properly
random sequence of pluses and minuses
which tends towards this growth constant
another example of what wouldn't work is
if I had a pattern if I had something
like plus minus minus as a pattern then
it went plus minus minus so if I started
with a 1 and a 1 it would be plus minus
minus is a pattern she'd go plus would
make it 2 then a minus would be 2 minus
1 so that should be a 1 then a minus
again 1 minus 2 I've got minus 1 then we
go for a plus which gives me a 0 then
we'll do a minus
which is going to give me a 1 and I know
that miners give me a 1 and I get back
to the original two numbers and then
that pattern will continue so that's not
growing at all
that's the oscillating up and down so
that doesn't have a growth rate because
it's not growing anywhere you won't
really see this coming out though until
you're using until you've done this for
about two hundred thousand times so you
have to go quite far and then you start
to see that this starts to tend to these
numbers you don't think someone watching
is gonna make some computer simulator
that will do this two hundred thousand
times and that's what they did that's
exactly what they've done so when they
were trying to calculate these numbers
they simulated it and they could see
that in the long term these miss was the
growth rate so in the 1960s they showed
that these randomized Fibonacci
sequences do grow I think that's a
surprise in itself because you know
we've got pluses and minuses don't they
cancel out but it turns out they don't
so these sequences are growing so they
could prove that it was growing but they
didn't know what the growth of it was so
that took till 1999 so we're talking 30
years later and it was calculated what
this growth rate was and that was really
hard
properly advanced maths proper advanced
computing but what they did calculate
was these this part of it one point one
three one nine eight eight two four and
that's as far as they could go because
it's really hard to calculate and that
was 20 years ago and in the 20 years
since we've worked out five more digits
and that's as far as we've got I know
Audrey hang on Audrey do you want to
hear about applications Audrey you're
not supposed to be in here out come on
actually go oh come on
how'd you go how'd you go
[Laughter]